Hola Buen día Pues se destaca que se
trata de un borrador de 16 páginas que
los países miembros del g20 han suscrito
de forma preliminar como también lo
estabas contando Ángela dice
textualmente el comunicado de este
borrador que los países este año han
sido testigos de la guerra en Ucrania ha
impactado negativamente la economía de
todo el mundo también dice textualmente
que has causado un inmenso sufrimiento
humano y que ha exacerbado las
debilidades de la economía global Pero
hay un consenso en lo que dice este
borrador al menos en la mayoría de
países y es en condenar enérgicamente la
situación en Ucrania Pero algo muy
importante también en este borrador que
debe ser ratificado es que se ha pedido
que se prorrogue el acuerdo para que se
siga exportando granos ucranianos y
recordemos que este acuerdo expira el 19
de noviembre y también se ha dejado
claro un rechazo por parte de los países
a la amenaza del uso de armas nucleares
básicamente lo que quieran estos países
es que entienden que esta Cumbre del no
es el lugar para tratar temas de
seguridad pero también saben que este
conflicto esta guerra en Ucrania ha
afectado la economía dice este borrador
que hubo opiniones diferentes
refiriéndose por supuesto la posición de
Rusia pues Rusia considera que se trata
sigue insistiendo en que se trata de una
intervención militar y no en un
conflicto para finalizar les digo que
entonces este comunicado conjunto este
borrador debe ser acordado por todas las
partes y cuando finalice el g20 en su
última sesión que es este miércoles se
publicará ya con el visto bueno de todos
estos países que son las economías más
grandes del planeta